you
all right I got it I got a refocus here
I have to refocus this is three check
now be very very careful about moving
your G pawns or yeah your D pawns okay
here we go a 30-minute tournament ah
okay let's offset that night for
starters mmm don't like how I'm playing
it already I'm gonna click Bishop move
this is a really bad start I should have
just played with the Sicilian all right
we're going to grab a pond and keep him
around probably here no yeah I'm just
going to keep him there make sure we get
castled take this night soon I need to
get my light square bishop flying let's
take him out
we trade before it's maybe too late
all right now I got some checks maybe
stay on the up file
oh let's see what's he doing I'm gonna
do this now oh my goodness my Queens
ready to be trapped
I gotta go here rook g3 hmm I have to
defend Queen takes pawn stuff
what did I just say what did I just say
man uh um look at my time
you
two checks I got a third just like that
whoo man those last three checks came
really fast that that game I was gonna
say that game flew but it didn't fly man
it it really went by slow cuz I was
struggling for some time right out of
the opening oh that's not a good start I
don't think because of this striking
rate at uh that's why it's usually
better to just form this structure yeah
they resigned it's already pretty much a
loss all right so start with c5 there we
go and then II six there we go that's
what I should have done against Ferrari
alright let's jump in this is now good
for me because I'm ready to take the
knight and now we have Bishop check so
this is already a win I'm going to take
that I don't need oh that's game over
probably someone not too familiar yeah
might be a an early three check player I
have a little question mark there that's
common if you're just starting out with
three check still getting used to the
the game the variant I got eight deep on
oh we got a check already lined up we're
gonna go see if I'm looking to take and
then get me Bishop here now I'm on f2
it's a pretty serious threat yep looking
to take here maybe
so let's challenge that Bishop I'm
tempted to take here let's go in for
this yeah I think I have enough fuel
here's a check here queen block queen c1
let's make next I need one more check
right yep I got two kings that's going
to do it back to tournament 12-8 634
players in this one got fire already
still plenty of time here these three
check tournaments could get in a lot of
games parens 1989 Carroll Khan now I'm
going to go in for threatening mate in
two that's already game over rooks and
Queens if they land one check it's
pretty much a guarantee they'll be able
to land a second check and their very
next move is that always the case
hmm probably this there's some crazy
I don't know block and then a check
thrown back at you I don't know why I'm
starting off with that but it should be
fine French and Sicilians are good as
black and 3 check I think and also
fishing pole ideas oh I
check here man I was only thinking of
Bishop getting here the Queen could go
to a five as well this is all big
trouble now don't know if it's
worthwhile to sack my queen for another
check let's just take care first that's
probably not worth it I'm on the bishop
threatening I should just take in here I
would have been better and then queen
here and now it's working
can us go to the corner ah this is
whatever now you throwing one check
that's going to be it oh no that was
their second check excuse me
but they're not going to get a third
check against me kingi one Bishop here
Queen to one of these three next all
right
we got twenty they resigned 2012 10 John
is up I'm getting berserk you know what
I should actually consider berserk in
three check because of how quick these
games could really end hmm
a little bit different compared to
regular chess you know these games could
be over in a blink let's drift over here
there might already be sacrifices oh so
much for that let's open this position
up
open it up I'm okay with giving this up
somehow I feel like there should be
something here let's just keep opening
it up
I don't know here they don't have any
time either and now we're lying the rook
we're threatening here
that's one check that's two we got a
third it's going to do it back to
tournament twenty four twenty Manny your
friend is up ferrari's withdrawn no he
is not
so I reference preserving but I don't I
don't know I still don't kind of feel
right about preserving okay so we're
going to go for this Knight g4 stuff um
I could take that on actually I'll go
here
let's do this bishop before I go here
I'll take him
and it give me the H file it's almost
certainly a loss let's just go here
prepare to meet Knight there or even
here
I want to dodge one of the checks get
out of there Knight you're no good
Bishop to c6
let's go here just in case there is some
back to back checking ideas I want to
get rid of one of their nights another
coin there missed that
so
bishop take with the queen I don't need
her there anymore looking to take on f2
with a knife first let's go at the fork
I guess Bishop takes f2 again I'm on
both rooks they really don't even want
to allow me to take to give even one
check now enters the rook and this is
going to be game over very very soon
that's one it's two and then three no
matter what back to tournament 28 24 24
re took another hit and they're ok got
fire 28 24 2012 20 minutes left and this
is the number 2 guy
and we've played this is what our
seventh game I don't know if they've
been mostly three check games or not
let's start with this pretty much always
have to take the knight in this
variation otherwise I'm hitting here
with check um let's go here and then the
idea is to hmm I'm doing this pawn sack
just to get my Bishop a clear shot at f2
I know they could Castle but still have
my eye on my eye on this I'm going to
sack that I'm not f - I should have
played h5 before Knight f6 I guess this
is really what I wanted to do it's an
interesting move okay I guess we're
gonna have a queen trade and I'm down a
piece but their development is a bit
backward I'm striking my bishops are on
the adjacent diagonals here I'm looking
at this they're going to push I have
this check hmm I'm really tempted to
give one check here but I don't know
what the good follow-up would be okay I
want to move my bishop and then get my
rook to enter here bishop efore next on
the knight rook exchange they're going
to queenside castle I'm running out of
fuel they're running out of time three
seconds two seconds I got the piece back
I guess we're going to go here yeah they
have that it's actually pretty scary
they don't have any time though
I don't have any time let's just stop
Bishop checks not the not the cleanest
end of that one but I'll take it
18 minutes 8 seconds we have 32 Ferrari
again okay II four it is Knight c3
before d4
all right I'm just going
take him out
and we're just going to open this
position up as fast as possible secure
each to my rook is opposite their Kings
so there may already be possibilities Oh
interesting I may be threatening to take
here actually I will be able to land one
check now take with the pawn because I
want this square next let's kick him out
of there get rid of the knight and then
we're going to do some rook lifts and I
have to actually stop rook takes G to
stuff
I think g3 is the way to go don't want
to go to a light square that's
surprising I could do I already have one
check I only need rooks coming over this
is a win rook G for HR I thought this
was necessary with the threat to take on
g2 and then play the other rook over to
g8 and give the final check they resign
36 26 24 20 okay let's keep going with E
for I do believe it is best for this
variant let's get the other night out
this is a pawn sack just like in the
first game against Ferrari if the bishop
plays here I'll have to be content with
blocking and then giving up the e4 pawn
but you get a lot of development and the
Queen Bishop really struggles quite a
bit for black in these three Czech games
so yeah let's open stuff up Queen b5 I
had missing these early checks I think I
will go in for a sacrifice here yeah I
only need one more check how do they
dodge this Knight check can't if the
King moves I take the bishop here with
check he's deadly I'll need one more
check see the knight of the bishop
that'll be able to finish black off
there that's the third and final 40 29
26 at the halfway point okay
are we gonna get paired up Ferrari again
okay I will revisit this opening play
the Queen out last time happy to get rid
of let's do this
and open up with d5 Queen sac is not
working on h2 let's get the clean out of
there take with the rook no just go here
and let's hang on to the rook have this
square covered Bishop takes pawn we have
skewers next Bishop d6 and the King
can't even take back I don't believe
let's go here first just to stop queen
Tigs g2 and maybe I take on g7 actually
yeah Queen d6 this is deadly no that's
one it's two we got this one next
all right back to termined 44 29 28 28
14 minutes left a lot of games in 42
players
I still have fire so far so good
okay oh my goodness I forgot I was
playing three check there okay so we
have pretty normal ish looking position
now mmm let's go here give me the H file
yeah that was I could have been painful
quick I could do a sacrifice here now I
could take with the bishop King is on
the same color square as their bishop
and same could be said for white less
than 40 okay now what commit King get
rid of the night a night versus
Bishop pending I am welcome to where's
their king gonna go rook takes H through
rate rook takes h2 is already on the
menu here King has to commit and I'm
looking to hunt down the King now it's a
little Airy let's go here then King in
the corner hmm let's open up this side
let's take here hmm don't know if I
should
allowed this um let's just jump in here
yeah okay I'm running out of fuel this
is a pretty Oh
that was definitely helpful that's a
check and we're going to get the third
check here at the pond or the Queen oh
man I did not play that right
I shouldn't have counseled queenside my
King was vulnerable to some major peace
sacrifice on the B file and then I don't
know I think I don't think he was any
safer castle than he was still on his
home square Tama Nader
all right Sicilian less than twelve in
the tournament okay this isn't a good
idea because I get B for
I'm going to give up the bishop es let's
just go here more modest post I want to
stop a five-night here stuff kick him
out of there and just develop it should
be seven they were maybe having a little
pause there to work out some sacrifice I
guess alright we'll go here get the D
file to play with
I'm not going to castle so quick they
have some space over here
Queen d6 how do they differ in the D
pawn
I guess the knight has to try to do it
I'm takes I'm taking the rook should be
a win yeah this is these are two checks
and now I only need one more
so that's beyond just an even exchange
they're only one more check hard to
defend trade the bishop and then get in
here yeah if the knight moves I give the
final check I can just weasel my rook in
actually okay that was helpful
probably probably couldn't defend that
at that point anyhow being down to
checks to none
52 36 36 less than 10 VIN VIN this is
the number 2 guy start with c5 could
they screen out early Queen out stuff I
don't believe works they're gonna try it
though um no I don't think it works you
could try it Queen takes and then Bishop
takes here I think I'll be able to dodge
a final check these guys are the ones
that scare me the most of course
might they go for okay now they're
actually prepping it so it concerns me
enough where I want to get the Queen's
off at this stage rule out these ideas
all together because there's
possibilities for this into the mix and
I think it'd be too much to bear having
completely the work that one out but
it's just me Leah my feeling they're
really in the think tank here 16 seconds
left only hmm well no well it wasn't
working before it's not going to work
now they had that earlier all right so
there Knight is the only one that could
really hurt me but suppose I just box
him out suppose I throat threats of my
own or is the rook go and I'll generate
stuff with my knight even this stops
Knight here I was considering this
before this is actually just me they're
down on time 5640 36 35 eight minutes
left okay four
re just finished I think we are going to
get paired up again there are 46 players
in this one no we got bored Joe okay
here we go stop Bishop takes f2 very
important Knights are worth more than
bishops in three check so I'm happy to
have that kind of exchange and I could
do it whenever really let's kick him
away I might actually return let's let's
take here in return pointed the King yes
big trouble I will be getting a third
and final check here there is a couple
checks I'm not going to take with the
Queen here I could go one more check but
that's it just go here just so it
doesn't open up my king but it doesn't
matter clean here next is can't avoid it
two checks each they resigned sixty
forty four forty three thirty six less
than seven have just about as many games
as Ferrari in there how many games
exactly I have sixteen in VIN VIN again
before it is okay definitely do this
no Bishop takes Knight with check let's
security for I can't rely upon him
anymore this is where he returned to
anyhow in the last game um I'm going to
take and then defend f2 yeah so they
could take but there's not going to be
follow-up checks here okay so they got
one check-in a little bit scary because
they have the night that could enter the
scene
let's go here offset their night queen
night definitely castling and I got to
watch out for Queen takes here let's
shut that down 94 is the follow-up and
I'm getting into d6 Knight g4 may kick
me off of this diagonal well what's that
about
I'll take here now let's not working
I'll take with the King because when
this opens up I don't want this to
happen with check although I just really
mess up now I'm getting the rook and I
could take the knight wits check
possibly let's do that that's two checks
I only need one more if they resigned
back to tournament 64 4846 as Ferrari in
a game I do not know playing now we're
going to see soon enough he has reserved
nearly every game he's flying a game
against VIN VIN number for a guy Tama
Nader again
c5 it is think against him the last time
I missed an opportunity to give a check
here let's see if they allow that again
no maybe somebody different let's go
here before Bishop d6 here we go
develop maybe age six is worthwhile to
keep the knight out of even thinking
about this stuff oh man
I shouldn't have allowed that okay
they're going to get one check in there
should I allow that I don't even want to
allow one check this was not good not
good I want to just get rid of that
night they should not capture here to
destroy my structure all right
this is a strong diagonal though ninth
year now I take the rook with check yeah
that Knight can't go anywhere well he is
going somewhere though how they moved oh
I had this checked though and then a
third check no matter what
back to term sixty-eight 53:48 only
three minutes left let's see we got next
parens before it is getting preserved
9c3 been here before developing a little
system here this was very very helpful
black did to allow this up a piece and
this isn't good about two pieces
threatening mate in a couple that's only
a second check they're a long way off
from a third I'm already threatening to
take here and then get the rook involved
coming up one two and then three
somewhere there it is
back to tournament 7250 348 two minutes
ten seconds left
okay no more players have entered really
46 is where we stand still efore let's
offset the knight right away Knight c3
before D form let's not touch the deep
on just yet at least um yeah let's just
take and look forward to development 94
Bishop g5 let's transfer the knight over
here they're playing without their light
square bishop here we go
let's go at this first could have taken
the night all right so night versus
Bishop endings are excellent for me but
I'm looking for more move the Queen rook
first let's just go here I think they
might have been preparing g5 just to get
the open G file okay let's go here
shooting for this stuff already starting
to be a very real possibility very real
I have a very active queen Knight g5
rook h3 and it's probably mating um
actually I could go in here still
because it's made at the end with rook
h3 yeah
forget about three check that's just
mate with the first check and that's
probably going to do it under 25 seconds
now another pairing not likely yeah I
don't think so that's probably going to
do it 76-59 fifty two forty two less
than ten yeah we don't get paired up at
this point okay that is going to do it
forty six players in this one we got top
there 76 with fire
Ferrari 59 with many berserks fifty two
forty two thirty at is page one two
three four and five
okay 2:46 of you that took part in this
good games all okay
you